The streets can be rough.
Don't be this guy.
A few simple precautions will keep the muggers off your back.
You will need pockets, worn clothing, and an angry glare.
Step 1: Put away that iPod.
Stick it in your pocket till you're somewhere safe.
Step 2: If you carry a wallet, don't keep it in your back pocket.
Instead, put it in your front pocket.
Better still, keep money in your socks.
Step 3: Instead of a pink polo, try a white t-shirt with stains.
If you must wear expensive clothes, consider buying a cheap jacket at a thrift store.
Once you're at your destination, you can just throw it away.
Step 4: Stop staring up at the buildings like a tourist.
Try to seem familiar with your environment. Periodically yell, "Benny, where you at?"
Step 5: Adapt an angry glare.
If you're having trouble looking mad, imagine you've just bought a used TV,...
...but when you got it home and plugged it in, it was broke!
Step 6: While maintaining your angry glare, do your best to project confidence.
Like dogs, muggers can smell fear.
Pretend that you're a judo master or that you have retractable adamantium claws.
By now, the thieves will be looking for another target.
Did you know because of its tiny number of residents,...
...Vatican City has the highest per capita crime rate of any country in the world?